speaking of crab legs Annie Lederman
told me she likes crab legs she told me
that you told her that you got really
fat but you look the same
what
there's rumors in the industry that
Bobby's gay wait so any Letterman I
thought it was her someone said to me
that they're like oh you saw Bobby was
he fat he said he's fat
yeah I texted with her and I said I'm
just getting really fat but this is some
throwaway thing that I say to everyone
like you don't say whatever because
you're not gonna see them anyway and I
don't post [ __ ] anyway so I was just
like yeah I look like [ __ ] you know
Ralphie may now know our tech getting
smaller cuz of yoga um kind of well you
know how they say like 90% of weight
loss is in the kitchen
yeah really if you don't change that
part like you don't change the outcome
of your body shape basically yesterday
so your partner our yoga instructor Kara
yesterday repeatedly said Bobby stop
calling yourself fat stop calling
yourself that she's like you know if
you're if you're happy in the weight
that you're in you feel strong the
weight that you're happy in your weight
clap you're happy in your way clap your
hands fat fat but then she was like but
lay off the pizza belly
stop eating pizzas every day yes I took
that as an offense you know private yoga
a big group it's private she does both
oh you do it we should I think we've not
have been invited you before well it was
an informal invite but we we should do
it we don't want to crash your you're
not crashing isn't you - Sun zoom you
could do it with us and yesterday I'm
kind of sick number one I've never had
an other I've never had I don't know
what other yoga teachers are like but I
call her my master and he's my master
and she her name is Kara out of Hawaii
check her out she she really worked me
lesson yesterday it was the heart first
of all for you that for those of you
this is who I was before yoga yoga
that's just a bunch of stretching
that's not a real exercise you know like
anyone that would do yoga I'd be like oh
yeah
yeah i also walk you know i mean like
that's how the level of i thought that
it was just like walking or lifting your
arm right
whew Yoga hard riding your arm right
it's right I don't know why I'm doing
this we do that a lot you're like air
traffic when you're happy with your
weight clap your hands fat fat weight so
but what would you say about yoga now
before you said no no so I'm gonna get
into it oh it is his most difficult
thing I've ever done in my life I've
been into a lot of tragic situations in
my life not a physical exertion you have
I've been beat up yeah I've been uh you
know you step this trainer you know cuz
Abby thought about one time that I was
gonna be like an action star my manager
she's like I know this guy you know he's
the best trainer in the world this I
call a muscular black guy and he used to
come to my house and he used to [ __ ]
rock you're not done and I'm on the
treadmill you yo you're not done and I'm
dying and then like if I would stop you
would grab me put me back on the
treasure not don't you know and I was so
hard this is way worse you know no way
that's possible
oh yeah dude it's okay it is what I love
about yoga is this she's like yeah
you'll be in a position right what is
that you'll be on a few get you be on
your leg like this one leg and you're
lifting it like this I'm just getting
making it right I'm like it burns right
and then well because you haven't you
know use certain muscles there before
right like you know some of us have
built up that muscle right but because
it burnt because you haven't new and in
my mind I'm like when would I ever be in
this position am i kicking if I was a
soccer player like this maybe this right
wow that's really good
right right but when would you ever
that's why this is petrified because I'm
never in this position so it's very
difficult you know you should have you
done yoga I have there's a youtube yoga
that I do yoga with Cassandra but hers
is mostly stretching so I like
stretching yoga I don't like working
yoga can you please do yoga you and Dave
- yeah though he would do it yeah maybe
I would just want to see him do it well
he doesn't want that
he's so he doesn't want to be seen he
can just be off I feel like I'm at a
position or a point with David that he
should be able to allow me to see him
yeah tell him that I think we're at at
that point I yeah I'm definitely open to
starting that conversation he's really
he that's like his worst fear though is
people watching him trying to exercise
like you the thought of like a workout
class it's just like the that's his
worst fear I would I in he could be
doing it perfectly I don't know why
because whenever I see David it makes me
want to laugh yeah he's funny he's just
a funny joyful you know bundle of joy
and I just know that if I saw him do
yoga I would probably burst into
laughter I wouldn't be able to stop
myself so maybe not do it okay how are
you guys doing quarantine like do you
guys hate each other do you love do you
spend time together
I'm just curious from other couples like
what's the vibe